і
доброго дня дорогі друзі шановні
колеги шановний дмитрій вікторович
Віктор Володимирович
а мені приємно вітати всіх
присутніх на цьому сьогоднішньому
заході хочу нагадати що 3 гроші
у Києві відповідно до
домовленостями між міністерством
освіти та науки молоді та спорту
україни та міністерством освіти та
науки Російської Федерації
продовжуються не освіта науки Росії
в Україні у вересні 2011 року не
освіта науки українці пройшли в
Російської Федерації ми переконалися що
це було плідне цікаве
захід який дозволив
зустрітися обмінятися досвідом
подружитися встановити нормальні by
латеральні зв'язки різним
представником освітніх структур
україною Росії за підсумковим днем
завершення дні освіти та науки
україни у російській федерації було
підписано понад 200 двосторонніх
договорів між різними
освітніми установами
дошкільному середньому від професійно
технічними вищими навчальними
закладами
нашими профспілками громадськими
організаціями під час проведення
минулорічних днів освіти та науки
україни в Росії народилося 2 громадські
організації
асоціація ректорів вищих навчальних
закладів України та Росії та
абсолютно не за організована
асоціація молодих дослідників
аспірантів Російської Федерації України
які в загальному обидві народилися в
внаслідок проведення днів нашого
освіти та науки в Росії як ми
домовлялися з візитом у відповідь у нас
проходять не освіта та науки
російської федерації саме та цього мені
дуже приємно вітати тут мого
колегу міністра освіти та науки
російської федерації професора ти
Дмитра Вікторовича
диванного понад 200 осіб з різних
регіонів Російської Федерації
представників усіх ланок російського
освіти та науки позавчора вчора та
сьогодні працюють у Києві у київській
області
встановлюють контакти обмінюються
досвідом
встановлюють якісь дружні зв'язки
або їх відновлюють дуже важливо, що в
план підготовки днів освіти і
науки Російської Федерації
в Україні нами спільно з
колегою було здійснено низку
прелімінарний заходів так наприклад
під час проведення засідання україна
російського світ державного
комітету в якому головування чи
адже президенти наших країн вікторину і
Володимир Путін був підписаний
міжурядова угода про
взаємне визнання документів про наукові
ступенях та званнях таким чином ми
пішли від недоцільні на погляд
процедури нострифікації тепер
талановиті дослідники українців можуть
навчатися в аспірантурі
вищих навчальних закладів наукових
установ Росії та навпаки і
державного зразка диплом
кандидата та доктора наук професора
доцента та старшого наукового співробітника
російського зразка дає всі права та
можливості працювати Україні та навпаки
українські дипломи дають можливість
працювати і займатися викладацькою
та наукової діяльності в російській
федерації
крім того, під час підготовки цих днів
ми також завершуємо роботу над
наступні дворічний програмою
гуманітарного співробітництва оскільки
міністр ліванів і я є крім свої
основні ще навантаження співголовами
гуманітарного підкомітету
міждержавної комісії
очолюють президенти наших країн
зараз дозвольте із задоволенням
попросити кілька слів сказати
міністра освіти та науки російської
федерації
Щиро Дякую
шановні дмитрийович шановні колеги
для нас сьогодні важлива подія
ми
підписуємо меморандум про співпрацю
між нашими міністерствами та формами з
банком України
справді ми відчуваємо сьогодні
зростаючий запит з боку громадян двох
країн до спілкування до обмінів до більш
глибокого вивчення мови культур друг
друга
це
закономірно тому, що все в меншій
ступеня
є якісь перешкоди
є бар'єри які поділяють наші
народи наші школи наші університети в
цілому наших людей
історичне
спільне минуле та сусідство та мільйони
людських зв'язків які є між
нашими народами безумовно є
факторами, які сприяють цьому
взаємний інтерес
ми відзначаємо в Росії великий інтерес до
вивченню української мови більше
мільйона російських громадян вважають
українську мову рідною ми знаємо що
Україна має великий інтерес до вивчення
російської мови
є запит з боку батьків на те
щоб з'являлися в школи більшому
кількості ніж сьогодні де російська мова
буде мовою навчання
і
у цьому контексті сьогоднішній захід
для нас
є дуже важливим і значущим ми
повинні створити умови для наших дітей
для здобуття повноцінної освіти
для виховання для освоєння всіх тих
культурних цінностей які лежать у
основі розвитку
наших суспільств наших країн майбутньому я хочу
подякувати нашим
колег та партнерів виконаний з банку та
я думаю що ваш внесок дуже важливий і
справді це перший такий приклад
соціально-відповідальної позиції бізнесу
в сфері
освіти та будинок один з небагатьох
бісквіт на яскравих зразків
такого соціального партнерства
між
суспільством з одного боку між органами
влади та між бізнесом
ще раз вам велике спасибі в цілому наша
завдання безумовно йти ширше ніж тільки
проект з будівництва
цією
російсько-української гімну дівки та
розширювати в усіх напрямках нашого
гуманітарного співробітництва
роботу робити так що все більше громадян
двох країн були бенефіціарами могли
реалізувати свої запити на підвищення
освіти на становище свого
культурного рівня на
поглиблення своєї соціалізації у межах
цих проектів дякую ще раз
дякую та й то лише вікторович третій
учасник цього меморандуму, і я прошу його
теж кілька слів про нагоду цього
чудового заходу
велике спасибі
по-перше і захистимо подякувати
персонально і вас немає гладкий вас немає
вийти за те, що ось ідея яка
народилася якийсь час тому отримала
таку
найпотужнішу підтримку на рівні двох
держав ми сподівалися що так
станеться дуже раді, що дійсно
за фактом це відбувається саме так ми
дуже раді, що бром інвестбанк який
даним акціонером якого є
грубим внешекономбанку державний
апарат корпорація також підтримав наш
наше рішення про створення російської
української гімназії в Україні в місті
києві
міністри дуже
яскраво і детально нанесли думки які
ось є у всіх тих, хто підтримує
цей проект для чого ми це робимо та
яку дошку ціль
переслідує
мета одна дати можливість громадянам
росії громадянам України
здобувати освіту навіть я думаю
якщо
обидва міністри нас підтримують і по
принаймні ніщо не говорить нам про те
що серед ця підтримка вичерпається на
майбутньому буде можливість у
безкудниково даної гімназії мати
атестат на отримання середнього
освіти
те, що називається тісто держава
просто україни та росії що дозволить
майбутнім
випускникам цієї гімназії на вибір
здобувати подальшу вищу освіту
або на території України або на
території Російської Федерації зі своєю
сторони тобто проект знаходиться в
перетворенні стадії знайду ми сама
важка стадія що складався
саме
заразити цю ідею з нашої точки як я
говорив вже дуже позитивні відбулася
зараз ми переходимо вже в технічну
тисячі фазу з кого ми сподіваємося що
досить короткі терміни нам вдасться
презентувати це ми дуже хочемо бачити
висока якість освіти завдання
промінвестбанку як інвестор створити
умови але знову ж таки були дуже великі
підтримці двох міністрів щоб калюжі нами
попередньо обговорено ми сподіваємося
що якість освіти буде
перебувати ну на максимально високому
рівні з точки зору освітньої
політики та двох держав чому
неухильно слідуватимемо тому
ще раз величезне вам дякую
за підтримку яку весь цей час уже
зрадили представили надали нам і
щиро сподіваюся що з нашою з вашою
гасити легкої руки чи нам вдасться
довести цей проект до логічного
завершення завдяки спасибі пропонують
вона перейти до церемонії підписання тем
більше що промінвест вам публічного при
представників громадськості
освітні першу чергу та
засобах масою інформації взяв на себе
найголовніші зобов'язання будинок
матеріальної бази все інше ми
зобов'язуємося допомагати
до речі
сопрано
не можна
Дякую